all right joining us now Missouri
Senator Josh Holly he weighed in last
night calling Tik Tock a quote geyser of
terrorist propaganda and the most
effective surveillance tool a foreign
government ever invented Senator Holly
joins us now Senator if that's the case
and I believe you know a lot more about
this than I do if that's the case why do
we allow Americans to even download it
why aren't we stopping
it we should be stopping it Sean we
should ban it and listen I think
communist China right now is just
laughing I mean you've got Joe Biden who
is bowing and scraping and begging she
to be nice to him while China walks all
over us and then you've got Tik Tok
which is basically the social media arm
of the Chinese Communist party and
they're spewing this anti-American
propaganda this virent anti-israel
anti-semitic propaganda and I think
they're just sitting back and they can't
believe that we're letting them get away
with it we shouldn't be letting them get
away with it John here's the deal on Tik
Tok it tracks everything you do on your
phone it tracks everywhere you go every
text message you send every email you
write and it's all that information all
of it's available to the Chinese
Communist party it's an Espionage tool
it's a propaganda machine and we ought
to ban
it I I I know I've heard people like you
say it and I'll be honest Senator I have
so much respect for you uh I don't know
as much about it believe it or not my
staff does not trust me with my own
social media and I have no access to it
uh I got into too many fights with Alec
Baldwin and Jimmy Kimmel and many other
famous people so I don't even know the
passwords to my account at this point
but in all seriousness if we know this
that would be a clear and present danger
to our national security just like Joe's
open borders is a clear and present
danger to our national security these
are basic simple fundamental things that
our government ought to be doing and
they're not doing it they seem to want
to talk more about climate change than
anything
else yeah yeah I mean you think about
this Joe Biden here he wants to beg
China to be nice to him because he's so
focused on trying to destroy this
economy he's so focused on all the
Foreign Wars that he's embroiled in so
here he is begging China he doesn't want
to get crosswise with him Joe Biden also
doesn't want to offend these voters I
mean the increasingly radical Fringe
element in this country that are his
base I mean this Pro Palestinian pro-
Hamas people you see him rioting at the
DNC that's the new base of the Democrat
Party he's desperately afraid to offend
them so he doesn't want to do anything
about any of this and the truth is Sean
we ought to be standing up here for what
is true what is right and also frankly
what is good for America it is not good
for America to have a spy app out there
where the Chinese Communist Party can
track everything we do and I'll just
point this out you know the United
States military all branches of the
Armed Forces have banned service members
from having Tik Tok and using Tik Tok
it's because it's a security threat it's
because they don't want them tracked by
communist China we should protect our
kids in the same way we got to ban this
thing Senator well then then can you
explain why every US senator every
Congressman every elected official is
not United if that's the case how come
that's not being
accomplished well I think a lot of it
has to do with money if you want to be
honest Sean I mean Tik Tok like all
these other big tech companies has a
powerful powerful Lobby in Washington DC
you know how this goes follow the money
always and what you've seen is Tik Tok
has spent m millions and millions of
dollars trying to say oh no actually it
it's okay we don't we don't really spy
on you we protect Americans data it's
all false we've had whistleblowers come
forward from Tik Tok and say America's
personal information our personal
information is available and accessible
in China that members of the Chinese
Communist Party can access it I don't
want that for my kids I don't want that
for any American and we ought to take a
stand here and ban this thing hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else